[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily so-called
doomsday call duel
laurie valo and chad dabell are charged
with the murder of her two children
and his late wife why it took nearly a
year and a half for the charge to be
filed
and the couple's court appearances this
investigation
is far from over an iowa farm worker
accused of murdering a college student
takes the stand in his own defense
christian bahaina rivera tells a jury
through an interpreter two men forced
him into hiding molly tibba's body
in a cornfield the bigger one i could
see that he had
a gun and the smaller one i could see
that he had a knife
plus fiery courtroom moments as the
trial continues for real estate air
robert durst
in the murder of his best friend susan
berman it's a dead end into a crashing
wall
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the so-called doomsday cult couple
laurie vallo and her husband chad dabo
are now facing murder charges for the
deaths of her two children
and his late wife for a year and a half
to bring justice to tammy dabel tyler
ryan and jj valo
idaho prosecutors announced the
indictment of lori valo and chad dabo
the couple is charged with the murders
of seven-year-old joshua j.j vallo
16-year-old kylie ryan and chad's first
wife tammy dabell
the announcement comes on what would
have been jj's birthday the thousands of
hours
that have been invested into seeking the
truth for these innocent victims must be
recognized
the couple went in hawaii two weeks
after tammy's death and while the
children were reported missing
the bodies of the children were later
discovered buried in chad davell's
backyard
officials say valo and dabel believe in
a doctrine to rid the world of zombies
and the human bodies they inhabit
friends previously testified the couple
believed
the two children had become zombies
according to the indictment
text messages between the couple talking
about tammy dabel being in limbo
and tammy being possessed by a spirit
named viola
the couple has been in jail since last
year on charges of concealing evidence
we know many members of the community
may feel that progress
on this case has been slow due to the
ongoing safety restrictions imposed by
the courts during the pandemic
we just recently were given permission
to present information
to the grand jury for their review court
records show dozens of witnesses
testified
over five days in front of a secret
grand jury lori is now facing 11 charges
including murder conspiracy and grand
theft for collecting social security
for the children after their deaths chad
is now facing 12 charges
including murder conspiracy and
insurance fraud for collecting tammy
dabel's life insurance
the penalty for the most serious charges
range from life in prison without the
possibility of parole
to the death penalty we will not be
disclosing further information about
what penalties we will pursue for these
charges
terry when it comes to the charges for
the children we've been waiting for a
long time
now you add in tammy dabo what do you
think took so long
and how do we get here you know when you
think about it a year and a half
is not that long particularly when you
have multiple defendants you have
multiple victims you have multiple
charges
and you have multiple dates and you add
the you know pandemic along with that
it really wasn't that long listen the
indictment itself has
nine counts ranging from murder to
insurance fraud
and chad and lori they are named
together in most of these counts
including the conspiracy
for first-degree murder of j.j tyley
and tammy so i think that we will
get some justice here because everyone
has been
involved yeah and still a lot of
questions floating around those
questions will hopefully be answered
as this case progresses to an inevitable
trial the defendants appeared in court
on wednesday for their initial
appearance
on the murder charges you understand
your legal rights here today
i do mr pryor did you go through that
notification of rights form with your
client
yes your honor i did thank you
all right uh mr dabel did you receive a
copy of the indictment that was filed on
may 25th 2021 a warrant
that was filed on that same date
yes i did did you have a chance to
review that with your counsel mr pryor
he did judge and we have no questions at
this time
the court took a recess prior to the
hearing today and uh had a sidebar with
counsel in chambers
based upon the information that was
provided to the court the court finds
that there's some exigent circumstances
as well as a motion it was made orally
to me to continue the
initial appearance by the defense to a
future time
a date certain has not yet been set
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney nima romani nima
as a former prosecutor can you explain
how this goes from a
tampering case to a murder case like it
did here
in the vallo de bella case bryant
prosecutors had more than enough
evidence to charge
chad and lloyd with the murders of jj
and tyler the bodies are literally
buried in the backyard
they're dismembered they're burned
they're tied up in plastic bags
and the self-side evidence puts the
couple in the backyard when the bodies
were buried
not to mention that chad flees when he
sees law enforcement digging up the
backyard so
not surprising that the murder charges
came forward the first degree in
conspiracy charges with respect to jj
and tyler
what is surprising however is
despite all these disappearances and
deaths involving this family
they charge chad with the first degree
murder of his ex-wife tammy
and charge lori with conspiracy to
commit the killer as well
yeah terry i know i keep beating this
drum and it's surprising to me
but the children's bodies are found on
chad dabo's property
now we've got alleged murder charges the
only question to me is
are these charges going to pull chad and
lori apart are they still going to be
tried together
you know i think they're going to start
the finger pointing remember lori has
been declared
indigent and she's married to chad he
could have assisted her as far as that's
concerned
and you know you have to think about
alex who also was charged with
conspiracy for all three jj
tyley and tammy he's tied into this
because
he had a burner phone and he allegedly
shot at tammy
and so i think that they are all going
to be pointing fingers
at each other including pointing fingers
at alex
yeah especially considering as nemo said
that one of the charges are for
tammy valo now lori is not charged with
her murder but only the conspiracy after
the fact so
maybe she doesn't want to go down on the
third murder and only wants to fight the
other two
that would make sense to me but i'll get
of course we'll see how this plays out
in the courts
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily attorneys get heated in the
robert durst murder trial
in california but first defendant
christian benejo rivera
takes the stand in the molly tibbetts
murder trial here his explanation for
the murder of the iowa college student
found dead in a cornfield
[Music]
next
[Music]
we're back the man charged with killing
molly tibbetts takes the stand in his
own defense
and says he didn't kill her but she was
in his car
long crimes anginate levy is here with a
riveting testimony
yeah brian christian bohena rivera
really he took the stand in
stunning fashion telling the jury a tale
about two masked men
killing molly tibbetts and then him
leaving her in the cornfield
with the help of two interpreters
christian bahina rivera told the jurors
his story did you tell law enforcement
the truth
that night
not all molly tibbetts was in the trunk
of your car
isn't that right yes
bahina rivera said he drove into
brooklyn the night molly tibbetts
disappeared
after two masked men broke into his
trailer one armed with a knife the other
with a gun
he pointed on a map where he was told to
go then the man with a knife got out of
the car
while the other man stayed with him did
you hear him say anything
uh well um you could hear a lot of
things
uh but i guess what i heard him saying
is uh come on jack
but pagina rivera said he didn't know
whether the man was referring to
tibbetts boyfriend
dalton jack he said the masked men
forced him to drive to a cornfield
and then left him there did you look in
the trunk
yes what did you see
a body the heiness said the body in the
trunk
was molly tibbetts at that point in time
did it look like she was alive
well at the beginning i saw like a
little bit of movement
but then after there was no movement
bahina rivera says he covered the body
with corn stalks so the sun wouldn't hit
it
he says he stayed quiet for weeks
because the men threatened his daughter
and her mother
then investigators came to question him
did you ever believe
that things would be better if you told
them what they wanted to hear
yes on cross-examination the prosecutors
seized on what bahana rivera
didn't tell investigators you told
officer romero that you
confronted mollie tibbetts on 385th
is that correct
say yes you never
mentioned two other men
is that true
correct prosecutor scott brown also
questioned bahina rivera about
admissions he made to officer romero
you also told her i did it
didn't i do you recall that
the truth no you don't remember asking
her that question
no no
now scott brown ended his
cross-examination by asking bahaina
rivera whether or not it was true that
he was the only person that could lead
police to molly tibbetts body he said
that was true
the defense has rested its case brian
thanks anjan here again with us is
criminal defense attorney nima romani
and terry austin terry after his
testimony where do you stand on bahina
rivera's guilt or innocence
listen at this point you really have to
wonder whether
it is the defendant's word against what
dalton jack said
and what the story might be as far as
the prosecution is concerned
so i think that most of the jury is not
going to
believe what rivera is saying here only
because the story is so
far-fetched it just so happens that two
strangers who were wearing masks they
appeared in his home and they
told him to drive and he drove one had a
knife one had a gun
it's just way too convenient and then
they
left him and he was left with a body in
his trunk
i don't think jury's gonna believe this
and i don't think that the jury
is going to believe that dalton jack is
the one who did this because
he has so many people who supported his
alibi so
it's just one person's word against
another
and even that definitely that the jury
could go that way but
let's think about the defense's
arguments could this be coercion in a
type of way
where they're saying behavior rivera was
forced to do these acts
and the that the murder charges are not
actually on him
and that the bearing of the body is
coercion could those get him off on
these charges
right you carry on this one this was an
absolute outrageous lie by rivera on the
stand today
and i expect both the jury and the judge
to punish him i mean
there is no way that the story makes any
sense there is a video
of him driving stalking molly tibbetts
he made admissions which now he's
actually
opened the door and missions that were
initially suppressed because of romero's
incorrect
brand warning those now all come in
because he
testified and perjured himself and so
previously suppressed statements
are now admissible during process
examination we know why this case is
going to trial because the defense
wanted to
preserve their argument to suppress the
confession
trial just denied that motion but they
wanted to preserve the right to
appeal that issue but now that he's come
and testified and testified
in such really an outrageous way i
expect this almost all white jury in
iowa
to convict him and convict him quickly
engineer your thoughts on the matter did
this testimony help him in any way
yeah i really don't think it helps him
at all if he was coerced by law
enforcement which he's arguing
he had 11 hours to come clean with this
story and say i did this under duress
and they could have protected his
girlfriend his ex-girlfriend
and his daughter all right we'll see how
this plays out of course he's still got
closing arguments and see how the
defense wants to tie all this
information together but
from the three of you looks like there's
going to be a conviction on the charges
thank you coming up on law and crime
daily the brother of an olympian is
getting a new trial
after the judge declares a mistrial plus
the accused boulder store shooter makes
his second court appearance
the dozens of new charges prosecutors
are filing next
welcome back turn to ohio where a
mistrial has been declared
for u.s army soldier tevin biles thomas
according to cleveland.com jurors in the
biles thomas case
received legal briefs from both the
defense and prosecution
during deliberations because of the
mishap the judge declared a mistrial
the 26 year old is accused of murdering
his cousin and two other men
at a 2018 new year's eve party biles
thomas
claims self-defense he's the biological
brother of olympic gold medalist
simone biles the pair did not grow up
together
jury selection for his new trial begins
wednesday
the accused boulder colorado grocery
store shooter is now facing 115 charges
ahmad al-alissa appeared in court on
tuesday as
prosecutors announced additional
attempted murder charges and 47
crime of violent sentence enhancers the
charges are related to people
in the store and people outside fleeing
back in march
when shots rang out ten people were
killed including one police officer
alyssa is expected back in court in
september for a hearing to review
evidence in the case
all right let's bring in criminal
defense attorney nima romani to discuss
more nima when you hear the sheer volume
of the charges against
alyssa in this case can you tell us what
the trial is going to look like and how
hard is the prosecution going after him
have to go after them hard you have 10
murder victims you have 47 others who
were at least in the line of fire and
they formed the basis of the attempted
murder charges so
this is what we call a slow guilty as a
prosecutor because
there's really no defense here it's
obviously him and it's just a matter of
time before he's convicted the only real
defense here is men so competent but
that's going to be addressed
before the trial yeah the only thing i
would add is even defense attorneys
would call this
a very long plea allocation so
definitely agree there
facts are very hard against him thank
you now let's check in with chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
on what he's digging into this week
thanks brian coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates
a troubling story about young athletes
and their coaches
we've all heard about usa swimming and
usa gymnastics
now the allegations of sexual abuse and
cover-up
involve the united states tennis
association in a new lawsuit
the usta is accused of failing to tell
their athletes or their parents
about coaches who were sexual predators
i was sexually abused by this coach
um from the time i was about 13 to about
15 or so the usta said it had no comment
for our report
that's coming up this week on brian ross
investigates
on the long crime trial network brian
thanks brian when we come back another
fire exchange
between the prosecution and defense in
the robert does trial the courtroom
drama you don't want to miss
[Music]
next
[Music]
welcome back attorneys in the robert
durst trial are fighting over witnesses
to show that the disappearance of the
millionaire's first wife is tied to the
murder of his best friend
the real estate air is accused of
murdering susan berman back in december
of 2000.
berman allegedly helped durst cover up
the assumed murder of his wife kathy
in 1982. doctors have taken the stand
saying it was unusual for kathy to not
show up
for her rotations during medical school
things got heated during
cross-examination
causing the judge to ask the jury to
leave then attorneys made their
arguments
so what happened your honor is the
witness was critiqued by mr
garren for having not been shown certain
documents
and being aware of the history of those
documents so
i said to mr garren i want to speak to
the witness but i want you to be there
so you can hear exactly what i say i'm
starting my head because
obviously that would be the ethical way
to do such a thing and that's what i did
i started to walk back there mr
chesnov starts screaming that not to go
back there that it's improper for me to
do this
i told him it's not improper and again
the reason that i was doing it your
honor is that
what is going on is that the witness is
being asked
about a situation with dr cook
dr wilk the surgery rotation etc when he
has no knowledge and when mr daguerreon
has specifically asked him
isn't it true mr lewin never showed you
any of those documents
defense attorneys accused the prosecutor
of coaching a witness a claim the
prosecution
doesn't take lightly
i don't think it's an unfair question at
all
and your honor most respectfully we're
going down this road
you narrowed the case to what it's about
these are their witnesses
we don't have a choice but to deal with
what they're presenting
as part of their theory of prosecution
which we have
asked to be limited on multiple
occasions you know we're not objecting
to them going in this area the court
made its own observation we're not
objecting the
only objection i had is they should not
be pointing out
an inference that somehow i was
unethical if they want to cross-examine
which they've already done regarding
kathy's alleged issues in medical school
have added it's a it's a dead end into a
crashing wall
but that's fine your honor i wanted to
be clear i don't think mr lewin was
being unethical i just don't think he
was familiar with the experience of
every defense lawyer in this courtroom
that has never seen a prosecutor talk to
a witness during cross-examination and i
was aware of the supreme court
case that made it not even a sixth
amendment violation to stop it
so i'm not accusing him of being
unethical i'm just
stating what our experience collective
experience has been
and i and i did ask you to prevent it
and
whatever happened after it happened it's
not an attack on him we're ready to get
going
all right let's bring in nima and terry
one last time nemo the lawyers seem to
be just as much a part of this case as
the evidence is
is that a good or a bad thing here
ryan it's not a good thing and the
reason is john lewin
fantastic cold case prosecutor here in
la county but he's been living with this
case for so many years
he personally interviewed bob durst when
he was arrested by the fbi down there in
new orleans something that you rarely
see and there's been so many
allegations of ethical impropriety um on
both sides with dixie guerin going after
lewin and vice versa and the judge
having to
admonish the jury i think the issue is
these folks they've been living
breathing with this case for so many
years more than five years probably
almost 10 years and it's just not
something that you typically see
that's why they're so emotionally
invested yeah terry i think i'm gonna
ask dan abrams to install a mic so i can
just have it brought down here like i'm
in a boxing match because
this is just another bout between
prosecutor and defense
how do you think it played out for the
back and forth between the two of them
brian if it's possible i think they are
both losing and they're losing the
jury's attention they're going back and
forth accusing each other like nima said
of unethical things even though the
attorney
there just said i'm not accusing anyone
of being unethical when you say
that the prosecution is coaching a
witness
that is unethical and in fact there
could be
a violation there or even worse so i
definitely think that unless the
defense has some sort of proof that he
needs to
not make those allegations absolutely
nima terry thank you very much for
joining us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you